all right yeah it is working out so my
name is Alison Berg with iam from the
University of Wisconsin and I come from
the verification / programming languages
community and over the past it's a year
and a half maybe two years I've been
looking at questions of how do we apply
these techniques to the to the to
differential privacy and in
privacy-preserving
randomized algorithms in general so this
work is joined with my student Calvin
Smith and my colleague Justin sue who
recently joined us as faculty and before
I started I'm just gonna give you sort
of a brief history of verification so
first there was touring right storing
1949 he wrote a very nice paper where he
you know was concerned about correctness
of programs so so he said oh look we're
gonna be writing programs they're gonna
be doing math is the math that they're
doing correct and what he did is he
proved correctness of factorial he had a
very nice proof of you know an
implementation of factorial a very nice
flowchart and he proved on paper that
factorial is correct in ever since
during in 1949 we've been working really
hard on automating these proofs okay so
just in the sort of 2000s beginning of
2000s up to now we've been able to
automate lots of proofs and one of the
key ingredients in our ability to
automate these proofs is the the growth
and development in sat solvers so we can
encode programs as circuits hand them
off to assets over and the Sat solver
can say whether a bad state is reachable
or not and people have developed
extensions of Sat solvers 202 subsets of
first-order logic so the Sat solver can
now understand the arithmetic can
understand the Rays can understand bit
vectors and so on things that show up in
in a programming language so over the
past few years I've been looking at
these tools and trying to see how we can
apply them to questions of you know bias
in decision making as well and then I
stumbled upon privacy which is the
opposite path that most people took from
privacy to to bias so looking forward I
mean all of these tools are really have
been you know working on on
deterministic programs so the properties
that were they're interested in
proving our you know simplify to reach
ability of a bad state or assertion
violations like assert X not equal to
null if X is equal to now this breaks
can we prove that it never breaks so
this is the kind of properties that most
of the work over the past 70 years has
been interested in and I've been looking
at you know randomized algorithms over
the past few years so looking forward
what we really want and specifically
what we want for this talk is a verifier
a push-button verifier where i can write
an algorithm I can specify a property of
interest and I can get automatically a
proof that indeed this property holds so
to give you a flavor when we started or
and also accuracy okay so you know
people who develop differentially
private algorithms also say that this
algorithm has specific accuracy
guarantees that the real answer is not
different from the random answer by too
much most of the time so when I first
started looking at this I you know I
opened the book by Dworkin Roth and I
went to an algorithm called report noisy
max which Dan fing talked about it
looked at the proof and it was like you
know a page and a half of text and I'm a
theory B person so I got get pretty
scared of a theory a proof and then you
know I went one more page and I saw the
proof of the exponential mechanism and I
freaked out completely and you know for
the theory people this is probably like
a walk in the park
they're simple proofs right but for me I
got freaked out so I closed the book I
went on YouTube and I wrote the
exponential mechanism and you know
showed up a lecture by Katrina Liggett
which was a very nice lecture so I
walked through that lecture at some
points I paused some times I went back
and you know at the end I think I had a
pretty good idea of the proof and what
the exponential mechanism is really
doing and then I tried to reproduce the
proof on my own and I failed completely
so I was like alright I'll just build a
tool to automate this proof process okay
so no I need no need to do it by hand so
we've been able to verify such
algorithms in a very small amount of
time like you know our tool takes 30
seconds actually specifically 22 seconds
to verify both of these algorithms
because they're very similar so they
take almost the same amount of time give
or take and so this is the kind of proof
that I'm interested in doing and
interested in doing it automatically so
the other piece of the puzzle which I
will not talk about but I will give you
a sneak peak sort of you know fresh off
the presses is instead of just proving
an algorithm that someone writes okay
but instead we want to synthesize an
algorithm automatically and the idea
here is we're gonna say say a theorem
that we want to prove meaning I want to
algorithm that is epsilon differentially
private and I will give input-output
examples of how this algorithm should
behave think of them as test cases like
in test-driven development right and
these input-output examples should refer
to the algorithm without any noise like
the perfect answer and what the
synthesizer will do is would learn an
algorithm and the proof that this
algorithm is indeed differentially
private okay so to give you an example
this is an algorithm from Gupta Roth and
Ullman it's called iterative database
construction and this is a rendition of
the algorithm in a language called DFS
by Marko
and this is really where the algorithm
is it's a recursive algorithm it's it
looks non-trivial it has many sampling
statements to be honest I've no clue
I've never read this paper but our tool
was able to learn this automatically
from just a few examples yes so we just
give it some synthetic tiny databases
some outputs we told it give us
something that is - I absolutely French
aliy private as indicated by this type
and it was able to discover such an
algorithm in a very small amount of time
matter of minutes so I'm not going to
talk about this but this is sort of a a
sneak peek of you know where we're going
with this and the sort of the short term
vision is we would like to aid algorithm
designers people like you who are
developing all these algorithms and help
them with automated tools that can
construct groups automatically that can
maybe complete some programs for them if
you know they're having trouble in the
design and the long term vision is we
want to put theorists out of work you
know they can go back to proving P
equals NP and you know they're the good
stuff so this is where we're going
so today what I'm gonna talk about our
two two works in in the verification
space
the first one is proving accuracy of
these algorithms and I'm gonna talk
about accuracy first and the reason I'm
going to talk about accuracy first may
be it may be a simpler property and less
interesting one than epsilon
differential privacy but it's the the
proof technique will elucidate the the
proof technique that we'll use for
differential privacy
the general theme that we're gonna
follow is we're gonna try to get rid of
probabilistic reasoning and encode
everything in logic and hand it off to
an off-the-shelf tool like a set or SMT
solver that can do the reasoning
automatically so let me give you a
flavor of how automated verification
techniques work you've probably seen
this before if you have I'm sorry
wasting your time here but here's the
idea this is a precondition which says
let's assume that the program begins
execution in a state where X is positive
and let's imagine that X is a real world
there's God's integer okay
and then we're saying Y is equal to X
plus 1 and then we're gonna conclude
that Y is greater than zero at the end
this is obviously true how can we check
the statement automatically we can
encode this statement in in first order
logic and it will look something like
this so notice that there's an
implication and what the implication
says that if we start executing with x
squared 0 we set Y to be X plus 1 this
implies that Y is greater than 0 we
handed this off to a set or an SMT
solver and it will be able to prove it
automatically so we all know what a Sat
solver is you know it's takes a circuit
and if the if these are finite bit with
integers then we can give it to a Sat
solver SMT solver is just a Sat solver
with with some theory solvers meaning it
can understand arithmetic can understand
arrays and other things strings and so
on that people have been developing on
top of Sat solvers so that's the idea
and this is sort of the proof technique
that I would like to do for differential
privacy
so let's imagine a very very very very
simple probabilistic or randomized
program and when we are talking about
randomize programs we are usually
interested in getting a real the actual
result or a good result with some
probability of failure so here we're
saying pick some probability of failure
P think of it as an input to the program
and we're gonna flip a flip a bit with P
probability of getting true and then 0
and 1 minus P probability of getting
false so this is the the distribution
right here and I want to prove that X is
equal to true with a probability of
failure of 1 minus P so this is you know
super simple but I want to do it
automatically and the question is how do
I do it
how do I encode this in first order
logic now I could potentially encode
this in first order logic but now
imagine a more complex distribution like
a laplacian or a galaxy how do we do
that so the idea is that we're gonna try
to exhume at eyes this sampling
statement okay so instead of dealing
with probability directly we're gonna
throw probability away and replace it
with non determinism sort of like what
damping did in his talk so this is a new
program that have sort of rewritten this
program into a new program that does not
have any probability in it and what I
want you to notice is that this
statement here the sampling statement
has been transformed into an assumed
statement so assume statement just says
that when you get to this point and the
program assumes something about some
variables in this case I'm saying when
you get here to the sampling statement
just assume that X is true okay and
don't worry about the rest and then it
as we are executing this new transform
program we are keeping track of a new
variable called W which is the
probability of failing to satisfy the
post condition usually W 0 so your
probability of failure is non-existent
because you haven't done anything so you
know you have freedom of doing the right
thing
and after you make this assumption your
probability of failure increases to by
one minus P because you assume that X is
true so their probability of not getting
X is true is 1 minus P so that's your
probability of failing to satisfy this
assumption that you have made and now we
transform this post condition or this
conclusion that we want to prove into X
is equal to true and the probability of
failure is less than or equal to 1 minus
P now this program has no probability
whatsoever
I can encode it as again a formula in
first order logic and I can hand it off
to an off-the-shelf prover that can come
back and tell me yes or no in this case
it will tell me yes we'll have a proof
so this is the idea of this is how will
eliminate probabilities we're gonna take
any sampling statement in the code and
transform it into an assumption and this
is where the ingenuity comes in is
taking a sampling statement in
transforming it into an assumption and
even in the case of a Bernoulli variable
the range of assumptions is fairly is
fairly large right so this is the
assumption that we made assume X is
equal to true I could have alternatively
said assume X is equal to false and paid
a probability of failure that is P the
inverse I could have alternatively said
assume X is anything so this is what I
mean by assume true so in this case X is
non-deterministic it could take any
value it wanted it wants to take and
then I will accumulate a probability of
failure of 0 because I'm assuming the
full support of the distribution
I'm not making any restrictions so I can
pay a probability of failure of 0 and
but then if I do this I won't be able to
prove the post condition because I can't
conclude that X is true X could be
anything so that my proof fails
so the the underlying concept here is
you know X is being drawn from some
distribution let's imagine that the
distribution looks like this I'm going
to make an assumption to transform this
into into a non determinism I'm going to
assume that X comes from a subset of the
support okay
for whatever subset I pick and I'm going
to pay a failure probability that is the
area under the rest of the curve that is
not covered by the subset that is that
is the proof idea and and going back
here what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
transform this program into one where I
don't know what the assumption is and my
task is to discover this assumption
discover the subset of the support that
it will help me in constructing the
proof so this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna say assume some relation fee
about this variable X I don't know what
fee is fee is something I would like to
discover and then I'm gonna accumulate
the probability of failing to be in this
relation fee of X no it's it's really a
relation you can think of it as a set of
values that X can take so i can assume
anything in the Val X could take any
value in this set this is just a boolean
condition right so here fee is
completely unknown and I would like to
discover it so it becomes almost like a
program synthesis or completion problem
where I have a program and it has some
holes in it and I want to fill in these
holes such that some post condition is
satisfied so now we can encode this in
in first order logic with some
quantifiers and the quantifiers will say
there exists some fee so now I'm using
the Greek fee but it's the same one
there exists some fee I don't know what
it is such that for all program
variables this constraint holds and this
constraint is really just encoding of
this program that we've seen before so
essentially what we're saying
to the to the to the first-order theory
solver is give me an interpretation of
the this relation such that the program
satisfies this constraint in other words
the program is correct you can find such
an interpretation this means that you
know this is true X will be true with a
failure probability of 1 minus P that is
that is the idea this is a lot of you
know hard work just to prove something
as stupid as this but but this
generalizes pretty nicely so let's
imagine that we have the Laplace
distribution so I'm drawing from the
Laplace distribution centered at X and
with some scale s now we want to define
a range of possible axiomatization of
this distribution ok there's many
possible ways of eczema teasing it and
I'm gonna think of all possible
axiomatization x' that are you know
centered around the mean meaning I can
take assume X is in this range or in the
bigger range and so on
so I can say that this is my axiom
family so the distance between x and y
is bounded by some log of some
expression and this expression is 1 over
some function f of the program inputs
and this function f is unknown depending
on how I instantiate it I will make this
thing this region larger meaning I will
have make a bigger assumption or a
smaller assumption if I make a big
assumption then my failure probability
is become smaller this is my failure
probability this is whatever I plug in
there and if I make a small assumption
meaning I force X and Y to be very close
to each other then I have to pay a
larger failure probability because I'm
making a much more stringent assumption
on the value of X or Y so so here what
we've done is sort of restricted the set
of proofs that we can discover by saying
the proof can only look at subsets of
the Laplace distribution that are
centered around the mean and and as such
we you know we sort of templatized the
the proof I mean there's infinitely many
possible proofs but at least we've you
know
restricted them syntactically to this
form
so let's look at an example that Dan
Fang discussed cases I think it's
enlightening this is the report noisy
max example and it is really taking just
an array of integers think of it it's
really a set of queries but think of it
just as an array of integers and it's
going through a loop and returning the
index R of the of the array element that
is largest in this array so here at the
end we're returning the index R of the
largest element except of course every
time we observe an array element Q of I
we're looking at a noisy version of it
and the and the accuracy statement of
this of this algorithm which is similar
to report noisy max says the following
imagine that you have a failure
probability P okay whatever it is at the
end you have this crazy statement which
really says that the array element that
you return may not be the largest
element in the array but at least
compared to all other elements as
indicated by this universal quantifier
compared to all other elements it's at
least that element minus some quantity
okay notice that this quantity is is a
function of the failure probability so
if you're willing to fail then you can
make an assumption you can make this
quantity smaller if you're not willing
to fail then you have to have a looser
bound and this whole thing fails with
the probability of P and now how do we
construct this proof automatically our
technique what it will do is we'll find
an exhibit ization which is this
axiomatization which says every time we
get to this point in the loop I'm going
to assume that the value that I'm
observing of Qi is this much apart
and this much a part is notice that
we've discovered this automatically it's
the length of U Q divided by P and the
failure probability will be in the
inverse which will be P over the length
of Q and then using an inductive
argument which I do not show in the
slide it will realize that you know
every time I'm executing the loop I'm
paying P over the length of Q and
therefore the final failure probability
is P by just the Union bound so there's
two steps to this to this proof
technique one is discovering this
axiomatization of these sampling
statements in this case we discover this
axiomatization okay thus turning it
going from probabilistic statement into
a completely non deterministic one and
then there's an inductive argument that
tries to essentially tell me what the
complete failure probability is after I
execute the full program and this is you
know we can we can synthesize and this
this exhibit ization as well as complete
the full proof automatically with with
no user help in a in less than a minute
any questions about this part of the
talk before I keep going yes yes this is
given by the user right so this is the
theorem that you want to prove and then
we prove it but constructing such
theorems or approximations is like from
scratch is an interesting question I
don't know how I could I could produce
ones but I don't know how useful they
are right yeah you know more complex
settings we supply like intermediate
lemmas and stuff also is that sort of
the kind of use you imagine
for this type of system for like more
complex analysis right yeah so I mean in
this case for instance our system right
now does not have any you can't say that
two variables are independent and that's
why it employs the you know conservative
Union bound to just perform the analysis
and and potentially give you a very
conservative upper bound but you could
imagine you know supplying more lemmas
changing the axiom family in which it
searches if you're using different kinds
of distributions maybe a Gaussian
distribution then you can you can supply
other axioms but yeah so that's that's
the envisioned
other questions
so I'm gonna move to the second part of
the talk in which we're gonna construct
automatic proof soft epsilon
differential privacy and we're gonna
continue the same theme of trying to
remove probability and and and use logic
instead by turning them into non
determinism so this is the the model
that we're going to use we're gonna have
a program takes a database and let's
assume that it returns a distribution
over integers and the property is you
know the standard we've seen it like a
million times the past two days but here
it is again in different notation you
know for any two adjacent databases any
epsilon the probability of returning
some answer a is less than or equal to
probability of returning answer a
multiplicative factor so what are the
problems this is this this part of the
talk is is is in line with with Dan
things talk the problems of course is
that you know constructing proofs of
differential privacy is by hand at least
is hard and error-prone and he showed
some papers where you know including Leo
tells were where some algorithms were
discovered to be incorrect and existing
automated techniques only work for
simple algorithms because they just
employ you know standard composition and
therefore if they want to if you want to
get a nice bound a nice tight bound on
epsilon you know you're you're you you
really can't at least not automatically
so our goal here is to automatically
prove differential privacy of advanced
algorithms that where the composition
theorem the standard composition theorem
is not applicable
so here are the key ideas so the first
thing we do is we look at this idea of a
coupling proof so a lot of you may have
seen the notion of a coupling proof from
you know convergence of markov chains
here we're using a different notion of
coupling that was introduced by Marko
and my co-author Justin as well as
others we're you know again we're really
I mean in differential privacy you have
two copies of a program and you want to
show how far apart they are and this is
this is the notion that of coupling that
we use and what we discover is that this
kind of proof feels like a game it's
like you have these two programs that
are running on two adjacent databases
and they're trying to run away from each
other okay and you want to pull them
back okay and you win if you can pull
them back and make sure that they're
epsilon apart at the very end so that is
the idea and they can trick you
sometimes as then finger showed they can
trick you and you really have to play
with the right coupling at the right
time so we can think of it as a game and
our goal is to synthesize a strategy to
win this game for any pair of adjacent
databases it becomes like almost like a
reinforcement learning problem where we
you know playing against the the two
programs that are running away and then
we reduce it to a program synthesis or
verification problem where our goal is
to construct a program cue such that for
all input databases some property fee is
satisfied okay so think of Q here that
we want to construct as the strategy or
the proof
so what is a coupling in our setting we
have a specific notion that makes our
proof system works it's call it's called
the variable approximate coupling or
just coupling for short so here we have
two probability distributions two two
two instances of Laplace they're just
shifted apart by one so this is this has
mean 0 and this has mean one and a
coupling in our setting is a ternary
relation that says you know if you pick
C any integer see in the first
distribution any integer see in the
second distribution the difference
between them is going to be Y which is
the inverse of the scale so specifically
the probability of getting C in the
first one is less than or equal to e to
the Y probability of getting C in the
second one so this is this is what a
coupling is it's a ternary relation that
connects two pairs of two possible
outputs from the two distributions and
and gives you the distance between them
now I can move these two distributions
apart now one is centered at zero the
other is centered at 2 and I can do the
same thing construct another coupling
this one says if you have Big C in the
first one and C in the second one then
the distance between them is 2y okay
because the other two apart and going
back to the first pair of distributions
I can construct many couplings in fact I
can construct infinitely many couplings
so in this case I can say that if I pick
C in the first one and C plus one in the
second one then the distance between
them is 0 Big Sur for instance 0 here
and 1 here 0 & 1 have the same the same
probability so the distance is is
bounded is the same it's 0 e to the 0 so
for any two distributions there is
infinitely many possible ways of
coupling them and sort of the the trick
of the proof system is discovering this
this coupling mechanism and in fact
we're gonna need multiple couplings at
the same time and this is why we call it
a strategy so you have to play the right
coupling at the rate right time
so this is the the proof statement is P
is differentially private epsilon
differentially private okay if for any
pair of adjacent databases any epsilon
there exists a coupling such that C
couples the two distributions meaning if
I run P on the first database be on the
second database this is a coupling for
these two output distributions and this
coupling C is of the form for any pair
of output C in here and see in the other
program they're bounded by Y and Y is
less than or equal to epsilon I can do
that then I have you know a proof of
epsilon differential privacy for any
value of epsilon now the couplings that
I've showed you in the previous slides
they're very nice
therefore the Laplace distribution and
they're very elegant because the Laplace
distribution is very elegant but the
output distributions of programs can be
arbitrarily complex and we want to
construct a coupling for these output
distributions of programs and the
question is how do we do it and it turns
out we can do it by composing multiple
couplings and getting a coupling for the
output distribution and as I said before
it's going to be a game the two programs
are going to try to fool us and and make
us not produce a proof and we're gonna
try to couple them in a way that we end
up producing a proof yes because you can
think of I mean the program is
parameterized its itself by an epsilon
yes PD is PDF that's right yeah
so again it's a game and I'm gonna you
know show you one run of the game and
it's funny because we use the same same
example but he had a horizontal version
of the example I'm going to show you the
vertical version so if you didn't get
the horizontal one you hopefully you'll
get the vertical line I don't know so
this is the report noisy max that we saw
before and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna let the two programs run on a
concrete input and then we're gonna try
to play against them so the first
program is going to start with nine zero
okay so these are the two queries or the
two elements of the array and then here
we have two adjacent elements ten and
one and we're gonna maintain this cost
variable and this cost variable is going
to tell us how far apart are the two
output distributions it's an over
approximation of the of the distance and
then at the very end what I would like
to do is I would like to ensure that
both r1 and r2 are the same okay and the
cost is less than or equal to Epsilon
whatever epsilon is in this case I'm
gonna leave epsilon symbolic I don't
know what it is so we have at the at the
end of this program we have three things
we have the output of the first program
r1 the output of the second and the cost
so the idea is that this thing here
should this ternary relation r1 r2 and
the cost should be a coupling that
proves the French Epsilon differential
privacy
so at the beginning the two programs are
running in lockstep and I'm going to use
the subscript here one and two to denote
the two different versions of the
program and the first one sets R 1 to be
0 R 2 to be 0 then both of them enter
the loop and at this point the first
program is looking at q q0 here q1 0
which is 9 the second one is looking at
10
so essentially what they're doing is
sampling from two different
distributions that look like this one is
sampling from this distributions the
Laplace distribution centered at 9 the
other one sampling from the distribution
centered at 10 and at this point a I as
the constructor of this proof I have a
choice and my choice is what coupling to
play and one coupling I could play is
the following which says I'm going to
assume that they pick the same value and
the distance between the two is going to
be epsilon over 2
which is really just the inverse of the
scale so this is the choice I make and
what happens is that now both of them
sample a value C symbolically I don't
know what it is all I know is that they
both have the same value but I don't
care what it is so now notice that we've
turned probability probabilistic
execution in two completely non
determinism I'm just saying that they're
both getting a value C I don't care what
it is all I know is that they both have
the same value and the distances between
them is going to be epsilon over 2 okay
so I accumulate that as as an additional
variable in the program now I can
continue execution for one more loop and
I will apply the same coupling next time
around I will accumulate one more
epsilon over two and finally my cost is
going to be Epsilon
and at this point both r1 and r2 are the
same because they both made the same
choices they both got the same value of
C in both iterations and the final cost
is less than or equal to Epsilon so what
I've effectively done here is I've
constructed a proof of epsilon
differential privacy for the specific
two databases Q 1 and Q 2 that are up
there the concrete that these two
concrete instances and the way I did it
is why every time you know the loop
executed every time we got to a sampling
statement I play the coupling where I
forced both to produce the same answer
so in every our game strategy
the one we played the one I showed you
in every iteration use this coupling
over here now the problem with this
strategy is that if you have any two
databases that are larger than two then
you will you can't prove epsilon
differential privacy so the best you can
prove is n times epsilon over two
differential privacy where n is the size
of the database or the number of queries
that you have that's what we're doing
yes if you had written the program
instead of Laplace of Q of I comma two
of epsilon you had written it Q of I
plus Laplace of 0 2 over Epsilon yeah
but it's it's it ends up being the same
so you can mistake it do this so you
wouldn't just couple at CC you would
couple it and C and C plus 1 like Danton
was talking about all right you could
you could do that yeah so essentially
all you want to do is you want to couple
them in a way that the observed value of
Q of I ends up being the same is always
producing the same right yeah yeah yeah
so if you rewrite it then you'll need a
different coupling and beep right you
use the same CC right because you're
looking at they they are exactly the
same so this is like doing by
composition but what he's saying is that
imagine that you're you're sampling from
Laplace centered at 0 and then you need
to push them apart by one
any other questions alright so so
essentially this strategy is not good
enough it you know gives you this bound
which is not bad but you know it's not
the greatest so it's not we're gonna get
rid of it it turns out that the strategy
the strategy that we need to play in
order to win this game no matter what
the two input databases are is the
following we're gonna apply this
coupling which which forces the first
execution to produce any value C and
couples the other one in such the way
that it sees C plus one and I know that
the distance between them is going to be
Epsilon and now in all other iterations
I'm gonna force them to play the
coupling that gives them zero cost okay
so whatever the two distributions are
I'm gonna force this one
and this one to produce the mean
essentially now the trick is of course
when do we play the first coupling and
when do we play the second coupling
right and now it becomes really just we
were synthesizing a program we're
synthesizing a strategy and the strategy
is a program that is just a bunch of
if-else statements and the program says
if some condition is true then play the
first coupling otherwise play the second
coupling okay and our goal is to
discover those two couplings and the
condition in which we play either of
them and danfeng hinted at the fact that
we need to observe the future and and
and in our case we can observe the
future by just hypothesizing what the
output is okay so essentially producing
a proof that is you know parameterize by
an output I'm not gonna show it here so
I'm gonna just go ahead and and just
list some examples that we we've managed
to prove excluding the exponential
mechanism the the sparse vector
algorithm and all of these were were
proved automatically in in a few minutes
so I've talked about automatic proofs of
accuracy yes yeah if it's possible in
just a few sentences can you translate
what you just did into solving the
standard game what's the strategy space
what's the payoff matrix you wish I
could do that I mean it is a game male
it's a game in the sense of think of
tic-tac-toe as a game right there is a
final state or a good set of final
States and you know I want to get there
so once we remove the probability I mean
there is no there is no stochasticity in
the process it really becomes just
getting to a final state the state space
is infinite in principle but for any
starting point yeah okay
right so yeah so we have talked to you
about automatic accuracy automatic
proofs of epsilon differential privacy
and the whole idea was to try to get rid
of a probability and and use logic and
exploit you know progress and sad
solvers empty solvers program synthesis
and verification more generally and I
have to say you know even though we've
made a lot of progress there is you know
there's many many limitations to these
works for instance we can only prove
epsilon differential privacy not epsilon
Delta or any other variance I don't know
how this applies to local differential
privacy the proofs of accuracy are again
limited so if you can't make independent
sumption zand and so on and automation
is always tricky you know there's lots
of work that goes into the building of
the underlying solvers so it's not
always you know just a you know using
off-the-shelf solver and will work or
work like that so there's lots of
engineering that goes in and I'm happy
to talk to any of you who are interested
and that will be thank you
[Applause]
why that's a good question I mean we've
thought about it for a while and and
they're just the partly the the
algorithm that we looked at the proofs
were fairly complex involving a lot of
nonlinear arithmetic and the solver is
that that we use SMT solvers are not
really good with nonlinear arithmetic so
in the cases where we had to deal with
nonlinear arithmetic like logs and lawns
and and all that stuff we had to do a
lot of again hard engineering work at
the bottom to make the solver work
that's right so I just wanted to give a
concrete example to show where the proof
fails but the proof indeed is completely
symbolic so it proves for any two
neighboring databases you've in the sort
of axiom system you're you've got
explicitly the properties of Laplace
distribution precisely there and I I
guess I'm wondering if um to what extent
could like would it make sense to
specify the program it's a joy that the
sort of appropriate properties of the
Laplace would be due to automatic
obviously you'd have to be able to
specify that the algorithm that
generates the random variable yeah it's
a nice way but the reason I'm asking is
that there are a number of a relatively
small number of different private
algorithms where the distributions that
come up don't have like clean closed
forms like the Laplace discretion yep
thank you one particular technique
called the objective perturbation Rogers
convex optimization the pencil and paper
proof uses like you know the implicit
function theorem and jacobians and like
calculus not of a particularly complex
kind but there's like a lot of layers of
abstraction that go into category and so
I just wonder if that's something that
could be sort of written in these
languages in a way that's easy to verify
or if it's just and I think I'm you're
not the first person I've asked this
question what did the last person answer
right so I mean yeah I mean I think I
mean there is that there's an issue of
extensibility right I mean you throw in
a new distribution you have to find the
right set of axioms and as you suggested
Laplace is pretty nice and the kinds of
axioms we need are very nice
but if you have a more complex
distribution like the one you suggested
then then you need an a clean way of
encoding a family of axioms and which
family of axioms do you pick is an
interesting question now I think you
hinted at something where you know I
could look at that distribution perhaps
at the actual code that is implementing
the sampling and try to infer a system
of axioms that could be used for the
proof this is possible it's an
interesting problem but I don't know how
exactly to do it if we could do it by
kind of by just observing the
distribution like by just sampling from
it and trying to learn some axioms and
then ask someone like you are these
axioms correct or not
then you could say yes and then you know
it's sort of like an interactive way of
proving an algorithm yeah yeah miss
unders miss what you said you're able to
do with the IDC integrative database
construction right yeah being able to
synthesize the the algorithm or
synthesize the proof of its differential
privacy I just wanted to give you a
sneak peek right yeah but but indeed it
does and and the reason you know it
works and works in a small amount of
time is is twofold
first the the that specific algorithm is
fairly parametrized and you have very
specific types on the input so it takes
two functions and so on so once you have
a very complex type of that form then
the space of programs becomes very small
the space of programs that are well
typed so so we have an algorithm that is
searching the space of programs but it's
guided by the type system so if it you
know starts constructing a program
realizes it doesn't match the the types
of the inputs then throws it away
if it starts constructing a program and
it sees that the sensitivity blows up
then it abandons that search path and
that's why we managed to to to construct
an algorithm that is you know
sophisticated enough that you know
someone got a paper out of it and you
know a small amount of time
[Applause]